.
Thank you.
All right.
We call the subcommittee meeting to order on House Bill 370, FN, and we have a proposed amendment to the bill, which unfortunately had an incorrect effective date, but the text of the bill of the amendment is what we're after.
And this would replace all after the enacting clause.
I've got a couple more copies here if anybody needs it but this provides for an amendment to RSA 266 colon 58A Roman 3A to read and to add in or afterward windshield or on the windows to the left and right of the driver.
This is where persons who require medical for medical reasons after attending on windshield or on the witness the left and right of the driver may apply for special permit pursuant to RSA 266 colon 61A Roman 9.
Then part two, RSA 266 colon 61A Roman 9 just adds in the same phrase there after the word windshield or on the windows to left or right of the driver.
So this is for anyone who applies for such permit.
And then such waiver shall be granted in accordance with this section and shall only authorize the use of aftermarket tinted windows with a light transmittance of not less than 35%.
That's changed 70 percent.
So that's the extent of the amendment.
The amendment that amendment is 2023-2383H.
You'll get another amendment because this one had 60 days and we had asked for 90 days for the effective date.
So any discussion?
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I'm fine with the body of the amendment.
It's exactly what we talked about.
it will, I believe, clarify and simplify existing language covering both the windshield and right and left windows of the driver and clarify when a special waiver is needed for medical purposes.
So I think we have all agreed what the body of of what we are trying to get to uh the only thing that we had a concern with the amendment that came from the original subcommittee meeting was the effective date and uh and through the best attempts we thought we had the exact but now it's still going to be changed.
I would have no problem approving from the subcommittee level what we have in front of us contingent upon that effective date of 60 days being changed to 90.
And I'll make that motion if you would like.
I agree.
I'll second it.
Okay.
And any other discussion of adopting amendment?
Well, we don't have the amendment number, so because it'll get a new number.
I don't know that it will.
Brad, will that get a new number?
It will?
You're right.
So it um so yes as soon as it's changed it'll will reflect that new number but um i think as far as the recommendation from the subcommittee goes we're we're good to go with this and uh and the newITTEE AND THEN WE'RE OFF AND RUNNING.
OKAY.
YEAH.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT I SAID.
OKAY.
Sure.
The motion would be that all of the body of the language in this amendment under 20232383H will remain the same.
The only thing that will change is line 15, which is the effective date, and that will change from this act shall take effect 60 days after passage.
It'll change to 90 days after passage.
Good.
Yep.
Okay.
Any further discussion?
Seeing none.
All in favor, say aye.
Aye.
Opposed?
Okay.
And since we did not have a notice on HB 37537, which one was it?
We can't discuss it anyway, so adjourn this meeting.
Thank you.
anyway so adjourn this meeting.
All right, good morning, everybody.
We're going to open up the subcommittee work session on House Bill 646, Eliminating Vehicle Inspection Mandates for Non-Commercial Vehicles.
As I said at the last subcommittee meeting we had, the bill in its current form would have a hard time getting through the committee, if at all.
So we were looking at this bill as a vehicle to make some substantive changes to the program to actually, no other way to say it, to make people hate it less.
Timing has been difficult, plus we just came up with a few other ideas, and just quite honestly, we have a deadline before us.
We do have at least two bills, possibly three in the upcoming session, that we can use as the vehicle for the changes we were proposing in this subcommittee.
So I'll recommend, we only have two of the three of us, but we can operate, that we ITL this one and just look at one of the future bills that we have to continue our work.
Oh, I'll do it.
Sorry, Mr.
Chair, I move ITL move itl thank you sir without any other discussion all right uh so the motion to uh recommend itl to the full committee um yeah the motion is to recommend itl to the full committee all those in favor aye opposed?
None.
Thank you very much.
Try to be quicker next time.
Thank you.
Hi, everybody.
Before we get started, Representative Crawford can't make it to our exec session.
Any volunteers to take out any notes on committee work session going in transportation.
Of all the retained bills that we had, the committee decided to do subcommittees on House Bill 55, 370, 537, and 646.
Those have been completed the recommendations are withstanding or ready for us for our executive session this afternoon but I wanted to look at the rest of them before we go into our exec session this afternoon in case anybody had any more thoughts or as you can see I did build in some downtime today if people had the desire to seek amendments.
So this may not take long, but I just wanted to run through the ones that didn't have a subcommittee.
So that being said, the first one just to review, just to prepare House Bill 375.
I was expecting Representative Sykes.
I believe this is his bill.
He is.
Has anybody heard from Representative Sykes?
Not today.
No.
Well, all right.
Well, this could be really quick.
So House Bill 375, does anybody have any thoughts on it in terms of any work that needs to be done before we go into executive session this afternoon?
That says relative to licensure of non-resident aliens temporarily residing in New Hampshire.
and what it seeks to do is a temporary license for 180 days for anybody that has sought asylum but not received a green card yet.
Anybody?
I think I have a question, Mr.
Chairman, and perhaps everyone can refresh my memory.
If I understand correctly, this was the discussion or where we got home was on the what constitutes an application or what stage in the process of application would trigger this opportunity to apply for work authorization.
Is that correct?
Oh, and you're applying for asylum.
Is that I don't know if others have recollections.
Yeah, let me look at it for a moment.
And relatedly, my recollection was that work authorization kicks in automatically after a year.
So we were talking about sort of the six months to a year period that there was an inability to get work authorization.
Is that others' recollection as well?
Yes, it's coming back to me.
Yes, the work authorization comes after a year.
This sought to give them a temporary driver's license for 180 days.
Then the conversation said, well, what are you going to do with the balance of the days from 365?
So, yes, you were remembering correctly.
That's why we did decide to interim study it.
I mean, retain it.
Again, I was expecting the prime sponsor to be here possibly with his own his own suggestions but um i'll i'll lead off by saying i'm not going to support the bill this way or with an amendment because i think the way we're doing it at the department of motor vehicles is sufficient um and again when you look at licenses, they have not gone through the system yet.
They haven't been vetted yet.
So these are people that have simply applied for asylum, but had not received their green card or permanent residency yet.
So I'll lead it off with that.
Anybody other, any other thoughts?
And if Representative Sykes does come in later, I'm a fair man.
We can always revisit it.
But anybody else from the committee on 375?
Representative St.
Clair.
Okay.
You know, since I talked to you briefly about this the other day, I reached out to some friends I have in Massachusetts that are in law enforcement, both on the state level and local law enforcement, to ask them.
As you know, in Massachusetts, they had just passed that bill where undocumented residents can get a driver's license.
And I was surprised that every one of them were in favor of it.
And the reason they gave me, all of them, this is not in a group, was that now they actually have some documentation on them that when they're, whether they're stopped in a car or on the street, they ask them for ID, they give them something that they can immediately track or find out exactly who these people are without any funny business, as one of them put it.
So I'm just throwing that out there.
Not that that has anything to do with this particular bill, but it kind of does at the same time.
So that's what I wanted to say.
And with regards to Representative Sykes, he may not be feeling well today.
I know he's had some health issues, so that may be what's going on right now.
Fair enough.
But anybody else?
Representative Brombo.
Were we able to get any confirmation of once an application is received, what sort of documentation we get back indicating that the application is in process.
Do we, do others have a recollection?
We can look, I can look back at the minutes or the meeting from the, if we take a break at some point today too, if we come back to this, but I seem to remember that being a sticking point.
Can you ask that again one more time?
Did we get clarification of, there would be confirmation of application received or application in process for asylum?
I seem to recall the discussion, the sticking point being someone can submit an application for asylum, and then would this trigger their ability to get their license?
but we know if there's been any initial review of the application, where the application is in process, or if there's some sort of confirmation of that or time frame we're looking at.
I don't necessarily remember that part of the debate.
Let's look at it after the fact.
Again, this is, again, I just wanted to touch over these to see if we had anything that anybody wanted to do as amendments.
We have time.
We'll certainly be debating this in its entirety when we get to our executive session.
We're just trying to get a feel and give an opportunity for any amendments.
Anybody else?
And we do have the director here, too, so some of these questions could possibly get asked after the fact so with nothing else on 375 we'll move right along um similar 570 you and this is also representative sites bill relative to real id compliant new hampshire drivers licenses once again i'm just inviting i mean having holding this work session if anybody has come up with anything that they think will help the bill along or otherwise um anybody representative c i was just uh recalling that the whole idea of the real ID was after the 9-11 attacks, where they wanted something to prove that somebody was a citizen before they had a driver's license.
because what the 9-11 attackers did was first went to a state that had easy driver's license provisions, got driver's license, and with a driver's license, you can do just about anything else.
Anybody else?
In this particular case, because I have had some conversation with a director, do you mind coming up and explaining how the whole process with Real ID works now?
Not to throw you under the bus, but...
Good morning, members of the committee.
John Morasco, director of Division of Motor Vehicles.
And I'm joined here today with Jeff Oberdank, administrator of registrations, and administrator three, Jim Bailey.
So some areas that go a little more micro, the three of us can certainly field them.
As far as this particular bill, what I can tell you is the Real ID Act does allow for those on a pending asylum status to be eligible through the eyes of the federal government for the REAL ID.
In New Hampshire, we don't do that.
I've spoken to representatives from REAL ID that run the program, and we are in full compliance with the REAL ID Act.
And the way it's been explained to me is that there are certain aspects of the act that you can choose to implement certain aspects of the act that you don't have to implement and that's a state decision but you're still in compliance with real ID so New Hampshire is in a good place when I offered testimony on this bill when it was coming through several months ago one of the the issues that we talked about we were still trying to get clarification from the federal government on the full vetting process and how that works.
So what was explained to me by John Mills from USCIS was that when somebody fills out an application for asylum here in the United States, and that's vetted by Homeland Security, they identify the individual as that individual, so you have true identity.
And at that point, the term that was used during the conversation was the individual is lawfully present.
I asked a little more about what lawfully present means with regards to the rest of the vetting process that they conduct, the federal government conducts, and the issuance of the real ID.
And I haven't been able to get anything back on that in writing.
The rest of the process that was explained to me over the phone was that there may or may not be an interview that takes place with the applicant, and then there is a more thorough background check that's done as time goes on, which can take in its entirety upwards of a year.
So really the decision before the committee here is, do you want to entertain the idea of issuing the real ID on a pending asylee based on an application that we now have true identity through the federal government and their database through the save system, or does the committee want to wait until the person has been fully vetted, either through an interview and a more intense background?
I check what that consists of.
I don't know.
That might take upwards of a year, and then that person would have completed the process and might then be eligible.
In the eyes of the Real ID Act, would, again, be eligible for the Real ID.
In the eyes of New Hampshire, and based on the current policy and the way that we operate and issue Real IDs, even with that, there would have to be more conversation.
Thank you, sir.
Anybody else?
Representative Gorski.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you for taking my question.
To get back to the vetting process, the initial vetting process that you, in your conversations with the feds, did they go into any detail on what that initial, I understand what you said in regards to, you know, the next six months or so, they do a much deeper.
But that initial vetting process, did you have any conversations of what that entails?
Thanks for the question, Representative.
I can assure you that I painstakingly tried to maximize my time with the representative from USCIS, and I asked a variety of questions that were micro, that being one of them.
What does lawfully present mean?
How do you get to that terminology?
And when somebody fills out the application, what is the level of vetting that goes on to establish that?
And what was explained to me was that because of the documentation that's presented, that they're able to confirm that that individual that presented that documentation, that's who that individual is.
And then that can be entered into the database, that they are in the SAVE database, the federal government's pipeline to the DMV, letting us know that they have been vetted at that first level and that that is true identity.
What that means beyond that, I don't know.
I don't know.
As far as looking at anything background-related, it didn't appear to me that that part of the process had anything to do with that.
Assessing, is this person somebody that is going to be able to stay in the country legally or not, it doesn't sound like that initial application and that lawfully present through identity has anything to do with what they do on the back half that was my takeaway thank you anybody else rip some coker thank you mr chairman what what was the time frame for that the the first background i don't know if you said i didn't um sorry i'd have to look at my notes on that i want to say the first background um and again please i'm I'm going from memory here, I want to say it was maybe 60 to 90 days.
It was a shorter period of time.
It might have even been as little as 30.
But that first piece for that, authenticating the identity of the individual was much shorter than the rest of the process.
I want to say it was 30, 60, or 90 days.
All right.
Thank you.
Representative Hill.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you for taking my question.
I have two.
One is, what's the minimum age that starts this, that a person can start through that process?
Is a person at age 16 able to get a real ID?
And the second part of the question was, at what point during this process of becoming or being identified as a legitimately in country, where is the social security number issued in this process?
Good questions.
As far as the real ID for the youth operator, youth operator is eligible for the real ID from that time of first license.
So that would be for somebody that's eligible through the real ID Act.
They would have that opportunity as well.
And as far as the Social Security number in the process?
Do you want to come up, Cheryl?
Good morning.
Jennifer Bailey with DMV.
So with Social Security card, after they get their actual documents that would be there for asylates, it's an I-94.
That's when they'd be able to apply for a Social Security card.
If they're not eligible, they get a denial letter.
Typically, we see Social Security cards are issued to those here on work visas.
If you're here on a student visa or you're not work-employed certified as an asylee, you would not get a Social Security number.
Anybody else?
Representative Jones.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
If I may ask the director, are you saying that this bill is too vague or maybe not use the word vague, not specific enough?
Is that what I'm hearing?
That's a good question.
I don't know that it's not specific enough.
I guess what I would say is based on the current New Hampshire's current policy of when to issue the real ID, I think what the bill is intending, you know, for criteria to allow somebody to be eligible for it exceeds the scope of currently what the policy decision is to extract that from the real ID Act.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you.
Anybody else?
All right.
Let me just I just want to clarify this, too.
The beauty of this exercise is it should make the executive session go much quicker.
But if the—so let me—if I have this right, the Real ID Act allows people, would say, an I-94 who have lawful status to be in the country to apply for a Real ID.
in New Hampshire.
Currently, we are not giving people merely with an I-94 a license.
We are making them go through the process or waiting for them to go through the process to get their permanent residency.
Is that how I...
No, so they don't get the I-94 stamped until they've gone through the complete vetted process.
So when they come into the country as an asylee, they apply for that asylum status and they get a receipt notice, an I-797 receipt notice.
That's what we don't allow you to obtain an original license on in New Hampshire.
You have to have a valid status, which is that I-94 card.
They don't receive that until they've completed the complete vetted process through UCIC.
Okay, so even with an I-94, they still don't have permanent residency though.
Correct, but we do allow those who are completed asylees, refugees, and permanent residents are allowed to get real IDs currently.
The only ones that we don't allow are pending statuses or those on visas.
They're not there who we don't allow to get real IDs right now.
Okay.
Let me think about this for a moment.
Anybody else?
I'm going to think on this.
Fortunately, our executive session is at 1 o'clock this afternoon.
If nobody else has anything or suggested changes, we'll move on to the next one.
I think that the next two were probably the reason, the main reason I called this.
Thank you both very much.
A little chat in a moment.
Let's move on to House Bill 650, relative to prohibiting suspension of driver's licenses due to nonpayment of fines or fees.
And if ever, to refresh everybody's memory, we held on to this only because we have a Senate bill, Senate Bill 13, which we retained as well.
I don't want to say the word contradictory, but you're going to decide on one before you decide on the other.
So I'll open it up.
Any thoughts on where 650 should go?
And is there anything done or anything, any changes that anybody may have come up with?
Go ahead.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I did a little bit of work on this over the summer, not nearly enough to say that it's ready to be passed.
but one of the major sticking points is that driving under suspension is a misdemeanor in New Hampshire as opposed to a violation.
So I did speak with Representative Lynn, who is a former state judge, and we share the concern that, you know, because you didn't pay a fine of a couple hundred dollars, that you may be then charged with a misdemeanor.
So it kind of creates a kind of a stacked charge on top of what should be really a minor violation.
So having a misdemeanor on top of what may be a non-moving violation or non-vehicle related violation is maybe not the best way to go and it's the kind of situation we would be running into with sb 13 where you may be responsible for a couple hundred dollars in fees for a rescue on a mountain somewhere and you know maybe i don't know what situation would lead to you not paying it and having your license suspended and driving anyway, but it would really be unfortunate to have somebody charged with a misdemeanor, which will stay on their record for what should be really a minor violation, if anything at all.
So, um, I'm not really prepared to support the bill, um, without some changes.
Cause I think the driving under suspension for any reason is kind of a complex issue.
And I don't think this bill addresses all the concerns, but I think we should take a deeper look at it and maybe look at SB 13 through that window.
Thank you.
Interesting.
Anybody else?
Rep.
Smith.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
So I don't know.
I start at the point where we're a fee for service state.
I paid for my license and unless I abuse it, I don't think I should lose it.
We just have the spider web of various reasons you can take a driver's license.
So for example, we've got one, two, like the third paragraph, including orders made pursuant to RSA 161B11.
I was curious what that was.
And conveniently looked up the wrong statute.
Hold up.
That was fireworks.
Here we go.
So child support.
You don't pay child support, you can lose your driver's license.
A case that I have personal knowledge of, a gentleman went to court in Sullivan County Superior Court because he had lost his job, not informed the Office of Child Support Collection immediately, like he should have, and ended up in arrearage.
He got a new job, began working that job, was going to pay it off, and in the middle of this time, he was called to a hearing.
He went into a conference room before the hearing in the Superior Court, worked out a payment arrangement, then went into the courtroom, but the judge wasn't having it, and said, well, do you have $800 on you today?
He said, well, no, sir, I don't.
Remand.
They took him to the county jail right then and there.
So what happens next?
Well, he didn't want to lose his job because the whole point is to get the child support money to the kids, right?
So his wife, ex-wife, had to find the $800 and pay it for him so that he could get to his job.
You suspend his license on top of that, then what?
She's going to drive him to work every day?
That's not good for anybody.
So I just, I don't like this entanglement that goes on.
Locking him up, okay, fine, figure that out.
If somebody owes me a civil penalty and they don't pay, fine.
Attach their paycheck.
I mean, there are other methods available.
I don't think it should have anything to do with licenses.
Any other thoughts?
Well, the one thing I'm going to look into, not that I, because I don't necessarily agree, whoop, Representative Jones, sorry.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
If I remember back when we were discussing this, there was just a common sense approach that if you owe money and they take away your license, you can't go to work to pay that money.
So it was kind of a common sense approach that I remember.
And I don't remember if it was a representative or someone from the public that said it, but it just made sense to me.
Well, if I remember right, I don't believe you can make much money if you're locked up either.
So I'm going to check my notes through any other room on who testified, because I still have the impression this has done as a last resort.
And if I believe, if I remember the testimony correct, we'll look into it.
Anybody else?
Representative Sellers.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
So I'm just trying to organize this in my mind that what we're trying to do is, or what we're thinking of, is being consistent.
We're either going to fine them for everything, and they could lose their license for everything, every type of infraction, or we really want to take that away so they're all consistent.
And right now, it sounds like the license itself should not be connected to any other infractions that are out there.
That's what I'm hearing.
From some, yes.
Others may still believe that it is a privilege, and it's one of the few things that they have to get the fines and fees paid, and it is used as a last resort.
So, yeah, that's where we're at.
but but but again too uh i just opened this up to see if anybody had done any work and wanted to make any changes that might make it more palatable for everybody uh i am going to check on a couple things in our break before the executive session unless steve or i mean representative smith already has i if i agreed with you with the fact that locking them up would be better than pulling their license, if this were to pass, does that happen automatically?
And that's what I want to look into in our downtime, unless you already have.
No, he hasn't.
So, my homework.
Anybody else on 650?
All right.
Yep, Representative C.
My notes show that pretty much everybody who testified, and there were a number of people, all were in support of this.
All right.
That being said, let's have a quick discussion on our last one.
It's still relative, Senate Bill 13.
I guess the decision on one will actually make your decision on the other.
But just in case there's something different here than I remember, take a look.
Yeah, this is the only change.
the director of motor vehicles of such persons's nonpayment and request suspension of the driver's license, the changes or driving privileges, or deny the issuance or renewal of a person's driver's license 21 days after providing the notice required by paragraph 4.
for, as the bill title says, for failure to pay search and recovery or search and rescue recovery expenses.
I don't know how much we need to talk about that.
I believe 650, your decision on that, is going to determine where you are on this, but I'll open it up.
Representative C.
One of the points of testimony on the SB 13 was that if you have the hike safe card, that that'll take care of all the expenses.
So you wouldn't have to worry about losing your license anyway.
That is correct.
Anybody else to offer on Senate Bill 13?
Representative Gorski.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
You know, in my notes here, when I remember the testimony, they brought up there were only seven examples.
So we're not talking here like there's, you know, 50, 60, 70 instances.
We're talking seven examples.
And in terms of the dollar figures, they weren't that very high.
So it just looks like this is just, as Representative C, it's off the hike safeguard.
Seven to me is not like a huge egregious number to go off and do something regarding taking away someone's license.
Anybody else?
I see Colonel Jordan here.
Did you want to offer anything on this for the work session or not?
Well, it's a work session, so absolutely.
My name is Colonel Kevin Jordan, New Hampshire Fish and Game.
The reason this bill came was because the House of Representatives a number of years ago during one of our multiple attempts to fund or better fund search and rescue came up with this law to allow us to bill reckless hikers or negligent hikers.
And in that bill, in that law, 206-26-BB, they had put in the clause that their licenses would be suspended if we were unable to collect this money.
But they never gave us, we never got the proper companion statute in motor vehicle to do that.
So we didn't feel comfortable doing that.
And the director of motor vehicles at the time prior to our current director felt that the law didn't have enough teeth, so we couldn't do that.
So you're right, sir.
We don't use it a lot.
I bill probably – we do 200 missions or more each year.
We bill probably 12 people total on an average.
The one thing that this law does help me with, it is a last resort after multiple letters and multiple attempts to collect, and we're unable to collect this money.
The only way that I ever get the payment is when we threaten to suspend a driver's license.
That's when people will pay it.
HikeSafe protects the negligence part of it, or a fishing license, or a hunting license, or a registration for an OHRV or a boat any of those things would trump this unless they're extremely negligent where people's lives are put at risk to go get them so but I can tell you that there will be a number of these folks that won't pay and I will be I won't have the authority or the power to collect that without some sort of a consequence for that.
So it started in the legislature.
That's why we came back here.
I'll certainly respect any decision that you make, but it was due to the inability to have enough teeth to get a consequence when the bill was put in back in 2015.
That's why we brought it back.
Thank you.
So according to statute, there's nothing, well, do you know of anything that would actually require them to be jailed if they didn't pay?
Or is this the most far as you can go?
This would be as far as I could go.
And I wouldn't want to jail someone because they can't pay it.
You it's uh some of these people are you know we quite frankly we negotiate this because some of these rescues can run into the hundreds of thousands of dollars if it goes on for four three or four days and we use helicopter services so a lot of times i've reached out to these folks as long as we can start a communication i've the attorney general's office has given me the authority to negotiate that down you know we've whittled that down to half or less than half um to try and help folks i only look to suspend licenses when i cannot reach these people at all and they completely avoid all calls all letters and have no intentions of paying and if we don't have some consequence there they won won't pay.
And we won't recoup that money.
So that's, I think, essentially why the legislature did it originally.
But they didn't put in the companion statute of motor vehicle to allow for it.
So, yeah, there's nothing there that I could do if we get there.
And I have a few of those folks in a stack now waiting because I stopped asking for the suspension until we got this matter cleared up that we haven't been able to collect on.
So it is a last ditch for folks that we can't or have refused any and all contact.
Thank you, sir.
Anybody from the committee?
I see two.
Representative Fox.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
thank you carl um you said that the threat of taking the driver's license usually gets a response i don't i can't think i cannot think of one time that we suspended a license i can think of a number of times we sent the final letter saying that if you fail to pay by this date, your license or privileges will be suspended.
I don't remember one time doing it.
How many of those threats for license suspensions has resulted in payment?
I don't know the exact number, but I can tell you that when we bill seven to 12 a year out of that, it's less than five usually that we don't, that will not contact us under any circumstances.
Thank you.
Representative Jones.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
And thank you, Colonel.
Yes, sir.
thank you mr chairman and thank you colonel yes sir do you use the term violator and is a violator someone who doesn't have the hike safe or any of those other licenses that you mentioned or is a violator something else no so they're uh they're actually we what we do in a mission after after a mission, we review why that call originally came.
And so we look at a whole host of things, the type of equipment they had, the weather conditions, all of those things.
And we make a determination based on all of that evidence of negligence or recklessness.
if in fact they have a hike safe card or they have a hunting license or fishing license where they've contributed to the search and rescue fund by the purchase of those things to some degree, then we don't bill them for that.
If they have not done any of this, if they have not contributed in any way and their actions, this whole rescue could have been avoided or their actions were negligent or reckless, then we would bill them.
Then we would find – I make the determination based on my field staff that this is a negligent hiker, and then I submit it to the Attorney General's office where it's reviewed again, and then they make the determination, yes, we're going to send a bill or no, we're not.
That's how it works.
Thank you.
Yes, sir.
That's clear.
Representative Sellers.
Thank you, Mr.
Jerry.
Sir, I was just wondering, how do you handle out-of-state or someone from California or Oregon or something like that?
And those actually, it's a good question, sir.
Thank you.
Those are actually the ones that I have the most trouble with because I think they feel safe being out of state, but it would suspend their privileges here.
And believe it or not, that triggers a payment in most cases because these people usually, not always, these people are usually have family here or they plan a return trip and they just don't want to have their licenses suspended.
So, um, the out of state people are the ones that I struggle with.
And, you know, I can't stress to you enough, I look very, I raised three kids.
I know what it's like to have a family and a tight budget.
And I look at the cost of some of these rescues and we are very liberal on my negotiations.
I'm pretty easy.
You know, I want them to pay something if they've contributed nothing, because I don't think it's fair to the sportsmen and women who are paying the bill.
But I don't necessarily hold out to have them pay eighty two thousand dollars for a helicopter.
I'm looking to have them pay the officer's time for doing that.
And I think that's fair.
I think the legislature, frankly, that was a fair resolve to that issue.
The problem is I don't have the authority based on the way the current law is written to to carry it out so it's a it's it's a threat i don't make because i can't i can't bring it like there's no consequence for it currently anybody else seeing no one thank you sir thank you um any other thoughts on this one interesting representative smith thank you mr chair if perhaps the director would indulge us i have a question probably best directed to him would you care to indulge us director thank you Thank you.
Thank you.
So in reading the bill, it references your authority to suspend in 263.56.
And am I correct that according to 263.56, the most you can do is a one-year revocation of suspension in this case?
If I could, sir, is Jen Bailey is the former supervisor of financial responsibility, so she's very familiar with that statute.
Good morning again.
So under authority of suspensions, we're able to suspend until the fine is paid so we used to suspend prior to my time suspend for search and rescue um it was the previous director that eliminated that ability so we used to suspend and we suspend you until we receive notification from fish and game that they are receiving payments or that they are no longer interested in that fine being paid.
Okay, follow up, Mr.
Chair.
Follow up.
So 263, Roman numeral 3 is pretty specific.
So where does the authority to suspend indefinitely come from, if not the statute?
I'm sorry.
I don't have that law in front of me.
Do you have this?
Two 50.
56.
I don't know.
Well, maybe afterwards, because this defines.
So the main title of Section three in this statute is that the directors shall not revoke or suspend the driver's license under the provisions of this section, the section which gives you the authority to suspend or revoke.
and for a period in excess of one year, except in the case of a person whose license is suspended or revoked pursuant to RSA 26356-1G, which is reckless or unlawful operation, materially contributed to an accident resulting in death injury, goes on.
Or, in the case of a person whose license is suspended or revoked under 26356 ID, which is incompetent to drive a motor vehicle to a reason of physical or mental impairment.
In that case, you may revoke or suspend indefinitely, provided that the person may request a hearing once every year thereafter for the purpose of reviewing the original order.
That is the end of the section, so I'm curious as to where you get the authority to do more than a year in any other situation.
So what I'm getting at is, unless there's some other statute authorizing you to suspend or revoke, this is the one you will have to adhere to.
And if the person can avoid their $100,000 bill for a year, then they're good to go, right?
I'm just reading through it.
So this section goes into habitual offender.
So those time frames of over a year are for habitual offender.
So if you go up above where it starts, the section one, two, and three, it goes in with how many points are assessed because we do it does list all of the reckless that we're able to suspend for certain minimum periods of time um but that goes into habitual offender but when we have a requirement from any other jurisdiction like child support for, for example, is another one that we mentioned, we suspend until that compliance is met.
I do see where you're seeing that year, but further up, it is talking about habitual offender information.
information i agree with you that section roman numeral 2 refers to habitual offender, but I'm referring to Roman numeral 3, which is its own main section.
And specifically talks about cases that have nothing to do with habitual offender.
You want to maybe think about it and get back to us later?
I'm not sure on that.
Thank you.
Yeah, we can all look into it.
That's why I'm having this exercise.
Anything else on Senate Bill 13?
Seeing none.
As I said, welcome, Representative Sykes.
And I just pulled this full committee work session together on the bills that we didn't have subcommittees for.
I did say I would give you an opportunity if you had been working on anything or any amendments or had any thoughts on any of the bills that we retained but did not have subcommittees on.
Hold on just a second.
No problem.
The reason I did this is because we didn't have subcommittees on them, if we came up with ideas, there is time to go to OLS.
So yeah, we can debate this at the executive session.
But thank you.
Sorry, I'm late.
Not a problem.
I apologize for everybody.
So you're good on everything else in terms of discussion and amendments?
Okay.
Well, again, I built in plenty of extra time for some discussions and opportunities to make it to OLS if we see something that we need fixed.
That was the reason for this.
Seeing nothing from anybody else, I'll close this work session, and we won't be back here till 1 o'clock to exec all of them before we leave today.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, everybody.
Welcome to Transportation for our executive session on retained bills.
Before we get started, if I can ask everybody to thanks for our substitutes today.
Welcome, Representative Weber.
I don't remember seeing you in transportation before.
And we have Representative Long.
You either.
I know we have one more here.
But anyway, thanks very much.
Oh, Representative Platt.
I'm sorry.
I was looking around.
I said, I know you have another one.
All right.
I'll open up the executive session on house bill 55 which do you have the title here relative to driver's education chair recognize representative sellers for a motion thank you mr chair i'd like the motion uh hb 55 to an interim study thank you sir is there a second second by representative hill would you care to speak to your motion uh as as we had a study on it already we realized that there's a lot more work that and thought that needs to go into this so we're just going to leave it as an interim study though maybe in the future we can look at it further thank you sir anything else from the committee yep representative sakes thank you so um i did attend some of your subcommittee meetings it was clear that uh you all were working very hard to try and find solutions but sometimes problems are more intractable than we would wish.
And so I could support an interim study motion for that reason.
Anybody else?
Seeing none, the motion is interim study.
I'll ask the clerk to call the roll when she's ready.
Vice Chair Gorski?
Yes.
Representative Smith?
Clerk votes yes.
Representative Hill?
Yes.
Representative Platt?
Representative Foote?
Okay.
Representative C?
Yes.
Representative Sellers?
Representative Sykes.
Yes.
Representative Rich.
Representative St.
Clair.
Yes.
Representative Fox.
Representative Rombo.
Yes.
Representative Bayou.
Representative Coker.
Yes.
Representative Jones.
Representative Weber?
Yes.
Representative Long?
Chairman Walsh?
Yes.
18 to 0.
All right, so our recommendation of interim studies adopted 18-0.
Closes the executive session on House Bill 55.
A minute to reset, and we'll go into House Bill 370.
Sorry.
Move consent?
No objections?
Consent, that is.
Thank you, sir.
I'm a little rusty.
It's been a few months.
Okay, we're going to open up the executive session on House Bill 370.
Relative to aftermarket window tinting on motor vehicles for drivers with medical conditions, Chair recognizes Representative C with a motion.
For House Bill 370, I move that we make it ought to pass.
Okay.
Motion's ought to pass.
Is there a second?
Second.
Seconded by Representative Hill.
This is open to further amendment.
Chair recognizes Representative C.
All right.
I move.
We adopt Amendment 2023-2395H.
Is there a second?
Second by Representative Hill.
Would you care to speak to your motion?
Can you read that number again?
Because I have a different number on the copy that was given to me.
What was that number again?
Representative C?
Two, three, nine, five, H is the last four digits.
Which one do you have, Representative Sykes?
We had some confusion with the effective date.
I've got a different one.
The one we're looking for, which is what he's got, say, 90 days after passing.
Wait a minute.
Thank you.
Can I have a moment?
Oh, here Sykes.
Representative Seed, would you care to speak to your motion on the amendment?
Okay.
This amendment is a replace-all, but it clarifies in RSA 266, colon 58A, Roman 3A, for persons who require medical reasons after market tinting on the windshield.
It adds after the windshield or on the windows to the left and right of the driver.
Part 2 amends RSA 266 colon 61A, which is the paragraph that allows the commissioner to waive requirements of 266.58A.
And after the word windshield, it adds or on the windows to the left or right of the driver.
And then the next sentence, it allows the waiver to be granted to authorize the use of active market tinted windshields with light transmission of not less than 35% instead of the existing 70% that's in the bill.
And the effective date is 90 days after passage.
Thank you, sir.
Anybody else from the committee?
I'll just add a couple of things.
Thank you for the subcommittee for doing this.
For anybody that remembers, this was the changes that put us in this situation were unintended.
This all occurred when we legalized aftermarket window tinting for everybody on their side windows at 70%, and this just got caught up.
The outcry was great, so we are basically just returning it to the way it was prior to making it legal for everybody to have the 70.
We didn't seem to have any issues then.
Hopefully we will not now that this is going back to the way it was.
In terms of the effective date, I did go over that with the Department of Motor Vehicles.
They say that's more than enough time, seeing as though the rules already existed at one time.
So anybody else from the committee?
Seeing none.
I guess I can just do a voice vote on the amendment.
All those in favor of Amendment 2395H say aye.
Aye.
Opposed, nay.
Okay.
So the amendment is adopted.
The motion on the floor is ought to pass as amended.
Anybody else wish to speak to it?
Representative Jones.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I came into this meeting ready to ITL this, but I think the amendment is a great compromise, so I will be supporting it.
Thank you, sir.
Anybody else?
Seeing none, the motion is out to pass as amended.
I'll ask the clerk to call the roll when she's ready.
Vice Chairman Gorski?
Yes.
Representative Smith?
Clerk votes yes.
Representative Hill?
Yes.
Representative Platt?
Representative Foote?
Oh, she's not here.
Representative C?
Yes.
Representative Sellers?
Representative Sykes?
Yes.
Representative Rich?
Representative Sinclair?
Yes.
Thank you.
Representative Long.
Yes.
Chairman Walsh.
18 to 0.
So our recommendation is ought to pass as amended 18-0.
I did hear a motion for consent.
Any objections?
Seeing none, consent it is.
I'll close the executive session on House Bill 370.
We're not going to be going in order completely.
We'll take up 537 in a few minutes.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I would like to move House Bill 537 inexpedient to legislate.
Motions, ITL, is there a second?
Sure.
Second.
Representative Smith, I heard him first.
Would you care to speak to your motion, sir?
Quickly.
It would seem that with the passage on consent of House Bill 370, It virtually meets or exceeds the request by the sponsor of House Bill 537, so it would make it unnecessary.
Anybody else from the committee?
Seeing none.
Motion is ITL on 537.
I'll ask the clerk to call the roll when she's ready.
Vice Chairman Gorski?
Yes.
Representative Smith?
Clerk votes yes.
Representative Hill?
Yes.
Representative C?
Representative Platt?
Yes.
Representative C?
Sorry.
You said yes, right?
Thank you.
Representative Sellers?
Yes.
Representative Sykes?
Representative Rich?
Yes.
Representative Sinclair?
Representative Fox?
Yes.
Representative Rombo?
Representative Ayou?
Yes.
Representative Coker?
Representative Jones?
Yes.
Representative Weber?
Representative Long?
Yes.
Chairman Walsh?
18 Coker.
Yes.
Representative Jones.
Representative Weber.
Yes.
Representative Long.
Chairman Walsh.
Yes.
It's at 18 to 0.
Okay, our recommendation of ITL or an expedient to legislate is adopted 18 to 0.
Motion for consent.
Any objections?
Consent, that is.
I'll close the executive session.
Next up, give us a few minutes.
House Bill 646.
Thank you.
Okay, I'm going to open up the executive session on House Bill 646, eliminating the vehicle inspection mandate for non-commercial vehicles.
Chair recognizes Representative C for a motion.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
On House Bill 646, the motion is interim study.
Motion to interim study.
Is there a second?
Second.
Seconded by Representative Gorski.
Would you care to speak to your study, is there a second?
Second.
Seconded by Representative Gorski.
Would you care to speak to your motion, sir?
Yeah, this one, because there are some complications on what was asked for, and there are some other bills apparently coming up for next year, that um this was uh the motion was interim study so as not to have an ITL that might interfere with those bills.
Yep, thank you, sir.
And this was one of the ones that we did hold on to to use as a vehicle for making some changes to the inspection program.
We are up against the deadline plus a a couple of new ideas that we haven't even started to get into yet.
So I concur with Representative C.
We're just doing the interim study versus an ITL to be on the safe side.
Anybody else from the committee?
Representative Sykes.
So my original inclination was to vote against an OTP.
In fact, I'd be looking to do an ITL for eliminating vehicle inspections for two years.
I have been cautiously persuaded by the chairman that there's a couple of things that maybe are worth fixing, and this will make it possible for those particular ideas to see the light of day, which I think is incumbent upon the legislature to always make sure that ideas get a fair hearing.
And frankly, for that reason only, I would be in support of an interim motion.
Thank you sir.
Anybody else from the committee?
Seeing none.
Motion on 646 House Bill 646 is interim study.
I'll ask the clerk to call the roll when she's ready.
Vice Chairman Gorski?
Yes.
Representative Smith?
Clerk votes yes.
Representative Hill?
Yes.
Representative Platt?
Representative C?
Yes.
Representative Sellers?
Representative Sykes?
Yes.
Representative Rich?
Representative Sinclair?
Yes.
Representative Fox?
Representative Rambo?
Yes.
Representative Veyu?
Representative Coker?
Yes.
Representative Jones?
Representative Weber?
Yes.
Representative Long?
And Chairman Walsh?
Yes.
Okay, 18 to 0.
So our recommendation on House Bill 646, interim studies adopted, 18 to 0.
We can.
I've heard a motion for consent.
Any objections?
Seeing none, I'll close.
Consent it is.
I'll close the executive session on House Bill 646.
Next up, I'm not sure.
Hold on one minute.
13.
I don't know.
Don't look at me.
13.
Senate 13, Senate bill 13 next.
I'll open up the executive session on Senate Bill 13 relative to recovery of search and rescue expenses.
Chair recognizes Representative Gorski with a motion.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I move to ITL SB 13.
Thank you.
You know, when I first heard this, I was kind of torn on this bill.
because between people who are not being wise in terms of going off and going off on trails, when I started to hear the testimony in regards to using, getting, having the ability to go after people's licenses if they don't pay, if they had to go search and rescue people, we start looking at the numbers.
There isn't a lot of numbers in regards to how many times they've gone out and had to bill people.
Even today's testimony in the morning, you know, he mentioned that, you know, when they sent out the letter regarding, you know, if you don't pay, we're going to do something regarding your license.
He even mentioned that out of eight, five totally disregarded him.
As a result, I don't see this as a vehicle, and that's why I think we should ITL this bill.
Thank you.
Anybody else from the committee?
Representative Sykes.
So I'm in support of the ITL motion.
I had a nice conversation with the colonel.
I explained to him that from my perspective, some of the legislative goals that some of us have had has been to trying to disassociate loss of license for non-driver-related offenses.
And this bill is antithetical to that notion.
and for that reason even though though I was a co-sponsor, as I said to him, mature reflection advises me to vote for the ITL.
Thank you.
Anybody else from the committee?
Representative Smith.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Since the whole point is to recover the expenses, I would like them to be able to drive to work so that they can pay those expenses.
Anybody else?
Seeing none, motion on the floor is ITL on Senate Bill 13.
I'll ask the clerk to call the roll when she's ready.
Vice Chairman Gorski?
Yes.
Representative Smith?
Clerk votes yes.
Representative Hill?
Yes.
Representative Black?
Representative C?
Yes.
Representative Sellers?
Representative Sykes?
Yes.
Representative Rich?
Representative St.
Clair?
No.
Representative Fox?
Yes.
Representative Sykes?
Representative Rich?
Yes.
Representative St.
Clair?
No.
Representative Fox?
Yes.
Representative Rombo?
Representative Bayou?
Yes.
Representative Coker?
Representative Jones?
Yes.
Representative Weber?
Representative Long?
Yes.
Chairman Walsh.
No.
16 to 2.
So our committee recommendation of ITL is adopted 16 to 2.
Is that going on consent?
I don't have a problem with it.
I'm not going to speak to it on the floor.
Two, it's borderline.
We'll put it on consent if that's...
I think you should check with Representative St.
Clair to see how he feels about that.
Would you like to fight it on the floor?
I have no issue with it being addressed.
Okay.
So with no...
You didn't let me get to it.
I was going to ask without objection.
So with no objection, we'll let it stay on consent.
That being said, I'll close the executive session on Senate Bill 13.
Give me one moment, please.
OK, here's where we're at.
This was not part of my plans, and I did hold the work session this morning, the full committee on these other bills that we didn't have subcommittees on, figuring that if we had any minor changes, we could sneak over to OLS and make it an amendment over here before we exacted this afternoon.
But I think some of the things that I heard personally are not going to get fixed that quick.
So I'm not going to be taking up $375 today, $570, or $650.
We're going to have to reschedule those.
If we want to stick till Tuesdays.
Next week's out because it's municipal elections.
So I guess we're looking at the 14th.
The deadline to report out is the 17th, so we do have the time.
So that's what we're going to do with those three.
Unfortunately, one more trip.
That'll take care of our executive session for today.
And there's only one other thing I've got to mention that I've been a little bit remiss on.
We've been asked as committees, standing committees, to create subcommittees within ourselves to go over the rules process as rules are adopted, just to make sure that whatever's being adopted in rules stays consistent with the intent of the legislation that was passed.
So I'm looking for volunteers.
We need four people.
It was three originally, but I guess we're looking at, we're looking at two of each now, two Democrats, two Republicans.
Think about it.
If it's something you want to do, I believe Representative Sykes are automatically going to be on it.
I'm just looking forward to having something else to do.
So we're looking at a couple more volunteers.
And again, this is just to go over the rules per committee, just to make sure that the rules are consistent with the intent.
What we can do, think about it.
When we do come back on the 14th, then I'll look to solidify that committee with the four names.
So is there anything else for the good of the cause?
Yes, sir.
Yep.
Mr.
Chairman, as we only have three bills to take up on the 14th, is it possible we could take them up in the afternoon?
And the reason I ask quite candidly is I have a doctor's appointment, and I would much rather be here than not be here.
But if I have to choose between the two, I'm going to the doctor's, given my recent events.
I had already had it in my mind we were going to do early morning.
We'll talk after the fact, but I think for other reasons reasons i need to keep it in the morning as well so but we'll talk afterwards all right all right anything else for the good of the cause representative platt i just want to say this was real tough duty thank you for allowing me to participate well thank you we try to keep it efficient i would have been even more efficient if we had gotten through all eight of them.
Well, thanks very much, everybody.
We'll see you in a couple of weeks.
And for those that made motions, they would like to give me some reports.
I do have copies in the office if you don't have the online format.
Can we email them to somebody?
You can email them to me, yeah.
Okay.
If you want to use online, email them to me so I can go over them, as always.
Thank you.